c'est un fou de fabrication des
instruments ça
j clin d'oeil à bouvante après robert
jean luc dominant à 45 ans et mon métier
bon la danse que me fait mille artisans
fabricants sûrement mille fans je
n'allais objet artisanal
donc on aurait envie de mater moi moi
moi t'as qu'à lyon n'a montré aucun cas
y en a aussi chez lui au point d'un
nouveau mode payant sa part ryan père
pauli en compte des instruments c'est
comme un a fait un sacré pari c'est si
différents instruments - moon mais faut
vraiment le bon soin bel instrument
policy tout autant aura tout en or à
cannes mais pour moi le carillon ça
toujours que mcpherson est grinçant des
dents mais avec d'autres choses toujours
comme ça
les traditions
au moins il faut le développer ces deux
courriers mali la passion lapointe la
richesse la joie de la lys à base un bon
rougail saucisses et ça fait cuisson un
ferry même adam a détalé commençons
commençons par les bons normalement les
bons éléments mais l'amitié
si le bo la rivière bahr al sawda
fédérant des galeries mais peu de fait
reconnu qu' série fait saquer minogue
est en vigueur sur tout ce qui m'est que
le maloya et mopar que la retransmission
et tombent pas dans l'oubli qui est leur
manière fabriquer le manier à jouer qui
continuaient pour bang my de m'impliquer
dans son temps dans des sens en 2 min
connu encore ils connurent encore deux
ans le félin qu'aion que seul un rouleur
que c'est un bad que c'est le mal